Guten morgen tim.
Ja so ähnlich wie bei elke am ende kriegt man in wegen Steuerhinterziehung.
Was wird hier gerade ein ticket video gemacht mit dem intro das ist doch wahnsinn hey gute laune wie gefällt es euch hier wir machen nichts mit politik nichts mit behinderten.
Das wollen wir doch mal sehen.
Und die sendung ist auch schon vorbei.
Das war's tschüss,
man ja noch nicht mal mehr zeit darauf hinzuweisen dass meine liken uns.
Na ja wie erfolgreich das wird entscheidet ähnlich ihr selber und auch nicht der user.
Fängt ja gut an lass lass uns erstmal kurz die formalien vom tisch kriegen.
Okay nikolaus welcher tag ist heute,
alter mann mit dem weißen part welcher tag ist denn heute.
Der tim hat gar keinen bart.
Scheiße jetzt bin ich gemeint oder.
Nikolaus ist da der nikolaus ist da.
Ich habe einen besonderen.
Ho ho ho.
Lass lass mich kurz die formalien noch wegkriegen,
buch netz politik nummer drei hundertdreiundzwanzig vom sechsten zwölften zweitausendundneunzehn soviel zweitausendneunzehn haben wir nicht mehr die dekade kommt langsam zum ende.
Du meinst die ursache.
Die uhr läuft es gibt überhaupt nur noch ein einziges wirkliches highlight in diesem jahrzehnt und das der nächste kongresse haben aber.
In diesem jahrzehnt der ist ja nächstes ist nächstes jahr neues herzchen schon.
Wo ist der jahrzehnt wechsel.
Na ja also wenn,
wenn der übertrag stattfindet dann ist das jahrzehnt durch so also ich würde sagen das kann man dann doch schon dann kommen die goldenen zwanziger,
da wird alles gut dann gibt es hier nur noch gute nachrichten,
ja der globale rechtsruck wird zurückgefahren alle besinnen sich wieder darauf dass das doch eigentlich viel angenehmer ist wenn man zur abwechslung mal freundlich zueinander ist so,
lieben anhalter so da hat er ja auch ein mädchen investments in einem café die geile idee wie das jetzt endlich alles durchzubringen wäre leider wurde dann die erde kurz danach gesprengt meiner umgehungsstraße platz machen,
das ein bisschen dumm gelaufen mal gucken ob 's diesmal besser läuft.
So fehlt auch schon zu den guten nachrichten diese diese woche.
Nee wir haben noch eine gute nachricht nämlich markus ist da hallo hallo markus.
Hallo.
Markus reuther bekannt aus international funk und fernsehen.
Aus funklöcher im fernsehen.
Katastrophe.
Ja genau es gab mal wieder einen guten grund dich einzuladen deswegen haben wir das auch gleich getan,
aber wir fangen an mit feedback.
Feedback genau.
Nämlich so einiges wieder zu erwähnen.
Genau olsen schreibt uns das löschen von twitter korn's finde ich eine ganz schlechte idee ich wollte mir eigentlich mal ein twitteraccount mit meinem,
richtigen namen zulegen nicht dass ich da aktiv werden will aber ich gehe davon aus dass mein name einmalig ist und bevor sich jemand anderes diesen account sichert und dann in meinem namen unfug macht
habe ich doch lieber
so eine partei gleich im keller ja ich meine warum wird eine wenn du jetzt irgendwie in social media account hast und hast du den leuten nichts zu sagen dann kannst du das doch auch da im rahmen deiner freien entfaltung,
machen.
Ja aber die annahme dass jetzt sozusagen ein twitteraccount der den eigenen real namen trägt der zweifelsfall sowieso nicht eindeutig ist ja gut also ich meine wie viel accounts müsstest du wieder sichern um da wirklich.
Aber es geht viel geschichte kaputt internet geschichte.
Wenn twitteraccount gelöscht werden.
Ja da gibt's da so viel schönen scheiß aus den uhrzeiten so viele fakes und schöne dinge.
Klar aber ich denke dass ihr schon dann damit schon eine menge erreichen würden wenn sie einfach die twitteraccount sie nie irgendwas getwittert haben mal wegnehmen so und,
ems die dahinter hängen was ja früher das argument war die nicht zu löschen das ist ja dann auch wirklich nicht nix fürs internet archiv,
also von daher ich,
ich bin durchaus der meinung dass man da mal ein bisschen frei putzen kann und die leute werden alle möglichen gründe haben irgendwelche accounts zu,
posten zu erhalten aber na ja gott sei dank dein problem.
Dann haben wir jetzt das wird hier schon was nicht mehr von wem der kommentar na toll tim doch.
Ich hab's nicht gelöscht was unsinn.
Ich hatte extra das bei allen hingeschrieben ich guck mal.
Ich hab's nicht gelöst.
Freigabe hat gesagt.
Genau port freigabe nee das also der kommentar war oder wir haben ja darum gebeten,
das uns erklärt wird,
oder das mit uns zusammen spekuliert wird wie denn dieser back in die digitalisierung box premium geklettert ist und,
da wird uns kommentiert das problem war nicht dass die portfolio gabe eines portos einfach um neun ports ergänzt wurde wäre man,
manuell vorgegangen wäre einem das auch nicht auf die füße gefallen und der kommentar ist von stiefel riemen er sagt in den kisten sind aber noch alias is für dienste hinterlegt
und da hatten die alias fdp oder hatte m,
p s eben nicht nur port achtzig beziehungsweise für vier drei hinterlegt sondern die besagten port rangers,
so einfach klärt sich das auf vielen dank stiefel rim ist immer noch falsch aber wir haben ja tatsächlich irgendwie den fehler auf einer code ebene,
vermutet dass also hier kein fehler offener,
auf einer code ebene sondern wirklich auf einer grundsätzlich nichts verstanden vom internet ebene wie tim
auch schon von vornherein spekuliert hatte insofern der punkt geht an dich ist also hier einfach nur ein reiner fall von vollständiger um achtung und hat gar nichts mit dem mit code zu tun.
Ja so sieht's aus.
Entsprechend kommentiert dazu auch x wenn ich mich nicht täusche weil die bezeichnung da für dieses alias,
sogar ps dienste was allerdings trotzdem nicht erklärt wieso man darunter im ganzen bereich von ports
zusammenfassen würde noch als ergänzung zu linus aussage scheiß telekom produkte doppelpunkt vertreibt diese geräte auch unter eigenem namen als sogenannte
ipt anstelle von digitalisierung box,
gerade im mittelständischen unternehmen sind diese weit verbreitet und die sind ganz genauso betroffen auch ohne zu tun der telekom ja also der entscheidende punkt war glaube ich etwas weniger,
was die deutsche telekom damit zu tun hat wir haben ja schon auch extra über den hersteller gesprochen aber insofern muss hier tim korrigiert wenn der sagt kauft geräte wo vorne draufsteht wer sie gebaut hat,
den den rat tim der ist da nicht so gut gealtert.
Na ja gut da weiß man zumindest wo man drauf schlagen muss.
Ja genau wer also,
unser unsere kritik wohl sollte hier eigentlich sich auch auf diejenigen beziehen die es verbockt haben selbst die telekom hat ja,
gesagt hier was so dann wurden wir,
wiederholt auf twitter und auf mehreren anderen kanälen darauf hingewiesen dass es sich bei stefan brandner das allerdings selbe um eine hip handeln würde die gar keinen,
morgen
morgen ländlichen ursprung hätte sondern eher ein abend ländlichen dazu lautet meine antwort never latte true story und dann hat sich noch der clemens fan bei uns beschwert,
zum thema sechsundfünfzig kilo bit pro sekunde sein funktional habe ich sehr schmerzlich die pflicht referenz
zum thema vermisst und zwar clemens schrippe in der show,
k m eins null acht funktional kaputt und dazu kann ich nur sagen ja stimmt sorry.
Genau liefern wir nach.
Genau womit glaube ich jetzt alles zu dem thema gesagt ist.
Da haben wir dann auch schon.
Oder doch nicht.
Funktional kaputt die telekom,
da sind wir wieder bei der telekom hat eine schöne aktion gestartet die aktion wir jagen funklöcher,
und da kann man sich also könnten konnten sich kommunen bewerben um über die telekom dann sich dazu herab lässt funklöcher zu schließen,
und da hat sie fünfzig freie plätze vorgesehen und es haben sich sechshundert vierundzwanzig kommunen bewerbungen aus fünf hundertneununddreißig kommunen in dreizehn bundesländern sind jetzt eingegangen,
ja das ähm,
sag mal wer so was in der ddr passiert würden wir uns da sehr sehr sehr drüber lustig machen hier als als besser wessis.
Ne das können wir uns auch darüber lustig machen ich meine schließen ja gar keine funklöcher sondern die betreiben nur land gewinnung an diesem netz inseln.
Machen neue netz inseln ja.
Ja und immer immer immer noch mal so ein so ein streifen drum rum gelegt.
Aber so schön wenn man so 'ne aktion ansetzen will.
Ja was wollt ihr denn ihr könnt jetzt noch zehn meter noch tiefer rein warten.
Jetzt also der bitcoin behauptet am häufigsten verzögert sich dadurch dass keine geeigneten standorte für mobilfunk station zur verfügung stehen an rund fünfhundert siebenunddreißig orten würde es denn jetzt bereit,
betreibern an fehlenden grundstücken oder gebäuden mangeln ja.
Die müssen ja jetzt auch tausend meter ne das waren tausend meter von leuten entfernt sein.
Windrad ja.
Ja schön dass ihr das jetzt ende zwanzig neunzehn dann auch schon auffällt dass sie gar nicht genug plätze haben nachdem sie jahrelang schwadroniert haben wie toll ihr netz ist.
Die last minute bewerbung bei der telekom kam aus dem brandenburgischen chemnitz tal sie ging am dreißigsten november um dreiundzwanzig uhr fünfundfünfzig fünf minuten vor schluss ein wahrscheinlich.
Bisher.
Wahrscheinlich über sechsundfünfzig kilometern,
können sie froh sein von wegen funktional kaputt hat doch gereicht ja fünf minuten vorher war das bei der daten trotz der durch muss man sich halt zeit nehmen muss als ich ein termin im kalender setzen.
Chemnitz zahl das ist das ist diese kritische region da um neuruppin also das hat mir schon öfter irgendwie so diese gegend.
Die frage ist welches sind die drei drei bundesländer die sich nicht beworben haben sind bremen hamburg und berlin oder.
Wahrscheinlich,
die flächen länder.
Wir werden in drei wochen haben.
Okay und jetzt das geile ist die verlosung die die telekom wird jetzt die.
Es wird gelost werden.
Experten der telekom werden die bewerbungen prüfen und dann die fünfzig gewinner bekanntgeben so.
Jury.
Und bürgermeisterin der abgewählt werden sollen weil sie beim beim.
Bei der verlosung von.
Lotto verloren.
Ja
Tja da würde ich vorschlagen wenn's mit wenn es mit dem funklöcher nicht klappt dann probiert's einfach mal mit 'ner bewerbung von olympiade hat der größere chance.
Das würde mich keiner mehr die müssen jetzt schon auf nordkorea zurückgreifen um überhaupt noch was loszuwerden.
Da bewerben sich auf jeden fall weniger ne das ist auf jeden fall besseres also die die chancen,
aus sechshundert ist auf jeden fall besser als bei einer schlechter als bei einer olympia bewerbung.
Ja hast du auch die gelegenheit mit zum diktator irgendwie von der presse zu stehen also macht auf jeden fall eine menge aufmerksamkeit.
Ich wollte euch ja das ist wirklich ein traum,
da hast du dann irgendwie vor allem die mussten ja in dieser zeit musste das ganze dorf hier auf die podcast kutsche verzichten ne irgendwie ihre meldung all ihre bewerbung abgegeben haben fürchterlich das ist wirklich nicht witzig.
Ja im podcast ja.
Ja die könnte man echt mal in pitchen andi scheuer.
Ja der ist bin ich auf der pitch mit liste wirklich ganz ganz weit oben nicht und nicht nur wegen der funklöcher ich meine gibt's jetzt eigentlich diesen untersuchungsausschuss ja ne.
Maul.
Genau wegen der gibt's denn oder nicht.
Ich weiß nicht ich das überlebt das alles denn der wird noch über die groko hinaus minister sein nein nee also mich wundert das so typen sich halten aber.
Mainzer selbst wenn die cdu nicht mehr ja aber ich weise daraufhin wir haben auch immer innenminister.
So dann kommen wir zu unserem hauptthema heute,
wofür wir dich auch eingeladen haben markus markus du bist jetzt auf der internationalen bühne des journalismus ist er.
Ja aber nur da.
Exportschlager.
Exportschlager tiktok story.
Habt ihr euch kann man ehrlich sagen keine sau gelesen in artikel ne.
Na das ist ja so ein bisschen spannend oder dass man in fox news läuft aber die leute die kern leserinnen und leserschaft glaube ich denk artikel irgendein scheiß neues netzwerk interessiert mich nicht
dabei ist größer als twitter also muss man einfach mal auch mal sagen also in deutschland so so.
Was sind die aktuellen zahlen oder.
Die variieren so ein bisschen natürlich gibt zick dog als private unternehmen das nicht heraus die zahlen aber es sind in irgendwelche marketing präsentation abhanden gekommen irgendwann mal und,
in deutschland sind das so ungefähr fünfeinhalb millionen user,
und in weltweit so um eine milliarde um,
also hier so nett angesagt für tiktok natürlich jetzt,
das muss man auch dann selber feststellen oh scheiße wir haben über zwei millionen user jetzt müssen wir uns mal melden und dann machen die das auch jetzt ja vielleicht muss man zu tiktok,
erstmal erklären was es ist weil ich glaub es hier die hörer schafft das auch nicht installiert hat auf dem handy ne.
Ich ich hab das installiert auf dem handy ja,
nicht dass ich da ein regelmäßiger user von bitten das ist halt so mal reingucken und so natürlich wird einem das ein oder andere mal gesteckt und ist ja auch nicht so dass da jetzt
keinerlei kreativität am werk wäre die zu bestaunen dann auch mal ganz angemessen ist allerdings wirklich auch wirklich in puncto,
hektik schlägt es alles was bisher da war also,
krasser kam das internet noch nie auf ein los getrocknet.
Genau die funktionsweise von ticktack ist so ich habe eine app,
und wenn ich die aufmache dann prassen videos auf mich ein ein hochformat und sehr kurze videos so fünfzehn bis dreißig sekunden
genau was ich da sehe wenn ich das aufmache ist der for you feed und das erfolg wird algorithmus zusammengestellt auf meine interessen und
groß wird auf tiktok nur an inhalt wenn er in den for you feed kommt quasi und da setzt auch so so die inhalts kontrolle eigentlich an.
Und ist der for you dadurch dadurch bestimmt was ich folge oder wem ich folge oder.
Was du so naja wenn du's eine weile benutzt und dinge likest und und folgt und so weiter dann dann couragiert sich das dann,
weil sie den zunehmenden maße auch ob sie aus deinem verhalten und wenn du es einfach so startest kriegst du dann quasi erstmal so was halt gerade,
insgesamt so angesagt ist wobei es eben auch glaube ich automatisch
auch schon so auf deine region hin gefiltert wird et cetera also kriegst schon irgendwie auch internationalen kram aber sehr viel deutsches zeug und
korrigiere mich wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe der p von tiktok ist vor allem der dass wenn du halt diese videos erzeugst,
eben die möglichkeit hast einerseits die dann in dieser app sofort sozusagen zusammen zu schneiden aber vor allem,
konntest du eben sofort auch mit musik das ganze machen das heißt der eigentliche drei fliegt da drin du hast halt ein riesiges musik archiv was du einfach so benutzen kannst du quasi diese rechte frage von vornherein
geklärt ist und kannst halt einfach zu populärer musik und dann eben zu dem was auch gerade aktuell als nehmen herum gereicht wird
einfach dein kram machen und zack fertig raus gepostet und und schon ist es da und hast dich diesen ganzen kopieren und das ist eigentlich so der schlüssel gewesen der das so verbreitet hat weil natürlich,
jugendliche hopsen zur musik so das funktioniert.
Genau also ist auch interessant dass du die mimt sich auch an an an musik stücken entlang eben gehen und so ne also das ist
jetzt prinzipiell so von inhalten ist lustige videos leute machen musik singen nach playback irgendwelche streiche,
et cetera ne also da ist jetzt nichts gegen zusagen dass menschen sowas machen und konsumieren und so,
ja also es ist so was sie so transportieren ist also wir sind das das lustige fröhliche unbeschwerte kreative soziale netzwerke oder plattform,
das ist die eine seite,
ja und was war das.
Tageschau soll jetzt auch.
Die tagesschau ist auch tiptop.
Tagesschau auf tik tak.
Singen die dann auch die nachrichten.
Nein na aber die machen das halt so lustig jan hofer mit krawatte ändert sich und hoch und so das finde ich an sich auch nicht schlimm also dass die tagesschau dahingehend sagt ey komm wir gucken mal was die,
also was die junge zielgruppe wie kann man die dann erreichen und die haben da extrem viele extrem viele zugriff e also gegenüber allen anderen social media dingen die die machen ist dass das erfolgreichste,
sie sind halt auch im besten.
Warte moment die tagesschau der der erfolgreichste social media auftritt der tagesschau.
Also der chef der chefredakteur der tagesschau gesagt es polarisiert alle anderen unseren social media auftritte vom erfolg her oder von der schnelligkeit wie schnell die irgendwie hunderttausend followern gefunden haben oder so,
ja wenn man so ein bisschen hintergrund weiß weiß man natürlich auch dass die,
tagesschau dort einen privilegierten account hat,
der eben auch in die besten feed reinkommt und dann eben 'ne große reichweite bekommt also das ist so.
Klar es hätte auch irgendwie.
Würde ich auch machen wenn ich tick.
Ja ja dass dass du versuchst wenn ich schon irgendwie die,
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk irgendwie beehrt mit seiner mit der reichweiten stärksten nachrichtensendung des landes dann sagst du hier kriegt er feature account ja.
Genau und jetzt also wie wissen wir zu dem thema gekommen
also die chris köder und ich habe diese recherche gemacht und wir sind irgendwann im august haben wir erstmal angefangen haben wir müssen sie mal anschauen das ist ganz schön groß was passiert denn da und dann.
Aber im september kam diese gerade in geschichte raus äh das eben politische inhalte nicht durchdringen bestimmte besonders dann haben wir selber auch so accounts erstellt haben wir versucht okay was passiert denn wenn ich,
irgendwie ein inhalt nehme wo der drin ist dann mein hashtag und dann immer nachgeschaut und dann so der hashtag den gibt's nicht,
in der suche finde ich nix und so und haben dann halt so ausprobiert haben dann das war so der anfang so der recherche haben dann,
viktor konfrontiert und auf einmal ging die videos genau das war so die zeit also dem guardian wurden damals,
die moderation regeln zugespielt und die haben daraus äh zitiert und das waren halt so dinge da kommt man also,
bevor vor dieser guardian geschichte konnte man auf tiktok keine politischen inhalte machen so richtig die,
bekommen also war ich alles unerwünscht ne also
dürfte es nicht die polizei kritisieren du wirst keine politischen figuren imitieren du durftest nicht,
über kontroverse ereignisse berichten kontroverse ereignisse taiwan da ne und so weiter ne.
Also in china kontroverse.
Nee generell also man durfte auch nicht den sozialismus den zu kritisieren die konditionelle monarchie nicht kritisieren du konntest also komplett anders ganze latte an politischen systemen die man nicht.
Also die erste regel der konzipiert ist du kritisiert nicht monarchie aber.
Also es war so ein ausschluss von von von politik und jetzt ist das interessante sowie tiktok,
inhalte formt und und und kontrolliert,
ist es nicht so dass sie sagen oh da hat jemand was für politik gemacht das ist jetzt gelöscht und der user merkt oh mein inhalt ist gelöscht,
zensieren da irgendwie rum sondern.
Du wirst in verschiedenen es gibt verschiedene abstufungen wie inhalte von der moderation kategorisiert werden können das eine ist,
ich lösche den inhalt dass es so das härteste es passiert aber nicht mal bei holocaust leugnen sondern das wird dann visual,
das heißt du selber siehst in inhalt aber niemand anderes.
Die dritte stufe ist dann not for feed ja genau bedeutet es kommt nicht in diesem großen for you feed aber es hat auch einschränkungen,
in suchen und hashtags dann gibt 's noch ein moment da kann ich das ein bisschen mehr teilen aber es kommt nicht in den großen feed und dann gibt's,
der inhalt generell dann kann dann wird er aber immer noch kann er mit sogenannten whisky verbunden werden,
zum beispiel kann ich dann eine drei punkt vier früher islam ofens genannt in moderation regeln ist zum beispiel
zwei frauen knutschen oder zwei männer knutschen also was ich inhalte die generell auch inhalte die alle die geschlechts identität zum inhalt haben das wird dann quasi,
georg locking mäßig in islamischen ländern in welchem wissen wir nicht nicht ausgespielt,
und da gibt es auch so dann wird es nur im eigenen land ausgespielt und also da selbst bei den generell erlaubt und auch für den feed zugelassen sachen gibt es eben lokale
ausnahmen und dann gibt's noch den features die nächste stufe das heißt jetzt kommt ein inhalt an und wird in einem review prozess von
dem marketing team als ah das ist ein geiler inhalt der pastor zu uns dann kriegt er weder noch gepusht so du kannst also noch ganz unten so boosten und das kann den marker kann ich auch setzen das sind so die die hauptstadt rufen es gibt dann noch.
Also das ist dann quasi das sie sagen ah hier lustiges video ne das macht den leuten spaß das.
Genau das hauen wir voll raus das kriegen alles mit dem mit eben bevorzugt behandelt bei der ausbildung.
Okay.
Dann gibt's noch auto auto er heißt das darf so sechstausend klicks machen,
und dann kommt der deckel drauf und dann wird's nordhoff it das haben sie zum beispiel mit den menschen mit behinderungen gemacht dass du quasi du es wird erstmal ausgespielt aber bei sechs dann ist immer schluss so richtig wäre.
Kann ich viral gehen sozusagen.
Viral gehen genau,
genau das das das ist so das sind so die die mechanismen die die es so gibt zur informations- kontrolle für deutschland ist es so dass die,
dass die moderieren die erste moderation findet in barcelona statt bei fünfzig bis hundertfünfzig views und die schauen wirklich alles an,
also das ist schon richtig krass also ich schau nicht die gegen einzelne frame von videos
haben dafür dreißig sekunden insgesamt zeit und ich höre nicht den ton und die gucken erstmal rein okay ist da irgendwie poren ist da irgendwas drin was was irgendwie nicht geht,
so das passiert bei fünfzig bis hundertfünfzig ansichten und der nächste die zweite stufe ist dann in berlin
die ist so zwischen sechs und zehntausend ansichten es hängt immer davon ab wie viel grade in so ankommt.
Was gerade okay wie gerade wie viele gerade diese schwellen reißen.
Ja genau und dann gibt's noch die dritte stufe die ist in die die dritte review ist so bei zwanzigtausend rum genau moderiert wird in barcelona in berlin und nachts in peking,
ähm also die nachtschicht macht peking und es ist so dass dort eben deutschsprachige knie sind und genießen in peking moderieren und auch hier sind ist die,
die die die leitung struktur chinesische geprägt also in der beim berliner standort ist auch ein chinesisches.
Wenig überraschend ja.
Genau das ist so grundsätzliche also,
aufbau von von dieser informationsquellen trolle,
ja und die einzelnen regeln also was wir haben dann was wir sehen konnten war.
Das unternehmen heißt ja mit dance.
Dance genau weiterhin und beides hat.
Und die sitzen auch richtig in peking also es ist so richtig mailand china.
Genau die erfolgreichste app die glaube ich mit einem chinesischen unternehmen außerhalb von china lancieren hat oder rausgebracht hat.
Okay ja.
Genau und jetzt was wir was wir jetzt sehen konnten sind die moderation regeln ähm.
Nachdem diese entscheidung getroffen.
Nachdem dieses guardian artikel eigentlich kam weil nach unseren informationen ist es so dass sie auf diese gardine berichterstattung mit,
großflächigen regeln änderungen reagiert haben und dann eben für den für diesen deutschsprachigen markt so sachen rausgenommen haben eben wie dieses set darf nicht,
darf keine politischen figuren oder amtes entschärft diese politischen regelungen,
nicht heißt dass es nicht also es gibt trotzdem noch so sachen sind drin so gummi paragrafen die zum beispiel sagen wenn er ein inhalt ein protest beinhaltet dann,
kann der auf nord vor feed schaltet werden wenn in zukunft möglicherweise,
gewalttätigen auseinandersetzung eine folge davon sein könnten das ist halt so jo,
david damit kann ich irgendwie ja da kann ich relativ viel mit löschen was generell aufgefallen ist ist dass diese regelung,
diese motivations regeln die sind sehr
knapp gehalten es ist in excel schied quasi der ein paar seitiges das ist nicht so wie so facebook hallo hier ist aus tausend seitige
regelwerk wo ganz genau und die bauchentscheidung quasi,
immer versucht wird es darf keine bauchentscheidung geben bei der moderation.
Das ist ja auch erstmal richtig oder nicht also.
Genau aber bei tiktok hat es ist das ist da muss man ziemlich viel bauch entscheiden anhand der kürze der moderation regeln,
ja also das ist der waage und nach allem was wir gehört haben sie noch die moderatorin und moderatoren immer so ungewohnt ist es jetzt muss ich das jetzt raus löschen oder nicht weil abbremsen nicht auslöschen,
genau den können wir diese regeln einsehen.
Ab der irgendein eindruck davon gewonnen wie viele leute da sitzen.
Dann wird keine genaue zahl ne.
Jetzt ist das ja so jedes mal wenn da was veröffentlicht wurde hat tiktok ja auch darauf reagiert und irgendwie,
eine neue behauptung aufgestellt wie die regeln jetzt sein oder die regeln auch geändert wie ist wie war das denn jetzt in zeitlichen verlauf.
Genau also als im september der der gartenartikel kam das hat uns die quelle berichtet dass dann
als reaktion darauf ganz viele regeln geändert wurden man muss die position von tiktok gegenüber dem guardian war damals ja nee das haben wir im mai geändert,
dann haben wir gesagt haben sie das dann im september geändert ist dann haben sie gesagt,
oder oder im mai und dann wird wir haben das früher geändert,
also wir haben uns nochmal was anderes gesagt als den guardian unsere informationen und das was wir also,
was die quelle sagt ist es wurde auch explizit darauf hingewiesen okay wir haben das jetzt wegen der schlechten berichterstattung gemacht und haben viele regeln geändert,
und ja da wurde das war die größte regel änderung die so,
bei tiktok in in langer zeit,
quasi da haben sie eigentlich diese ganzen muss ich das so ein bisschen so vorstellen also ich oder ich stelle mir das sofort kann ich nicht jetzt also dass sie quasi die haben,
diese chinesisch geprägten regeln genommen und dann haben sie den internationalen globalen wout dieses unternehmens gemacht auf einen riesen erfolg,
wir haben jetzt diese chinesischen regeln und das,
kollidiert halt nun mit den rechtsauffassung und auffassung von meinungsfreiheit in anderen ländern und jetzt kriegen sie kritik und dann reagieren sie darauf.
Ja aber nicht besonders elegant.
Ja es gab ja auch noch andere regeln die dann auch weiterhin geltend waren also es gab dann auch so eine regel wie attack und tiktok attack und tiktok heißt wenn du harte kritik an tiktok übst,
dann bist du nordhoff it,
du wirst auf jeden fall aus dem aus dem for you feed ausgeschlossen ich sag also elf finde ich voll scheiße wie die die user oberfläche hier voller back drin,
zack wird nie durchkommen also attack und tiktok ist raus und gleichzeitig hatten sie sowas wie ein konkurrenz nennung,
verbot oder der hatten dann eingeteilt direkte konkurrenz zum beispiel whatsapp oder snapchat,
wenn ich die nenne des winterfest zeige das logo zeige was wir dann bin ich sofort aus dem aus dem feld raus selbst wenn ich facebook irgendwie also das heißt ich mach die nenne die konkurrenz oder,
wenn facebook mehr als die hälfte des videos vorkommt dann ist auch wird's auch weggedrückt,
und dann hatten sie dass die regel die jetzt am meisten auch noch aufsehen erregt hat und wirklich krass es ist halt diese,
dass die regel nennt sich inhalte die besonders für wunderbare personen zeigen.
Ja das ist das mit den behinderten menschen oder,
dicken menschen oder irgendwie
mobbing gefährdeten personen haben sie das ist ihre schöne regelung dafür.
Na die haben sich halt genau das prinzip ist quasi ist ich habe die regel ist sehr kurz da steht da drin wenn die person downsyndrom hat,
ein erstelltes gesicht oder artist ist also abgesehen davon wie entscheide ich in,
wie entscheide ich irgendwie entscheide ich innerhalb von meinem dreißig sekunden die ich das video sehe ob jemand artist ist wenn er das nicht,
rein macht also abgesehen und die idee dahinter war wir machen,
menschen mit behinderungen oder menschen die irgendwie verwunden sind weil sie einen großen leber fleck haben machen wir unsichtbar damit die nicht gemobbt werden
also ich gehe nicht an die mobbing und sagt ey ich
ich lasse euch weg sondern ich mache halt einfach beschränkt die reichweite von menschen mit behinderung konsequent ein und was sie da gemacht haben als als als,
der kontrolle war dieses auto er diesen deckel drauf also nach sechs tausend klicks ist schluss
und sie haben riskier gesetzt was heißt ja wird nur in deinem eigenen land abgespielt das heißt du
schenkst die sichtbarkeit von menschen mit behinderung ein das ist entgegen aller forderungen ja
jahrelang oder jahrzehntelang fordern alle verbände die irgendwie mit inklusion zu tun haben hey sichtbarkeit ist das wichtigste
in der kamera und dann kommt unter dem sagt ne die möchten wir schützen euch indem wir euch nicht.
Bleibt immer schön in eurer ecke am rande der wahrnehmung am rande der gesellschaft der seite schön unter euch und werdet nicht geärgert und okay toll toll dabei könnte.
Ja vor allem das argument ist ja auch unglaubwürdig also ich glaube dass sie dann einfach doch eher ihre eigene,
plattformen in anführungsstrichen schützen wollen oder sozusagen verhindern wollen dass es dafür bekannt wird.
Ist ja schon so dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt selten passiert dass menschen mit behinderungen ziel von sport oder häme werden das ist korrekt,
aber das ist etwas was die bitte selber entscheiden ob sie,
ob und wie fern inwiefern wie weit sie da gehen wenn sie sagen ich möchte ein tiktok account haben,
dann soll braucht nicht tiktok die zu bevormunden sondern das können sie selber entscheiden ja es gibt ja auch menschen die,
gezielt mit ihrer behinderung und einem,
einem ironischen blick darauf arbeiten ja in ihrem,
in ihrer außen wahrnehmung in ihrem influencer influencer sein ja.
Interessant war halt auch das wie tiktok ergeht sie haben gleichzeitig kampagnen so hashtag kampagnen body positive city gemacht und haben auf der liste der dicke frau,
die sie quasi immer gedeckelt haben und wir haben halt also dem gleichzeitig diese policy gefahren dass sie nicht sichtbar sind und haben aber so schön wettermäßig irgendwie hey body positive die unter den,
eingeschränkt werden auch ganz viele leute die regenbogen fahren irgendwie hatten in dem profil und gleichzeitig ja da haben sie aber auch hashtag kampagnen gemacht für.
Kann es sein dass sie versucht haben die leute da in unterschiedliche babels zu ziehen.
Ich nee ja also ich meine die hatten einerseits diese diese regelung da gab's aber auch noch eine liste,
von besonderen nutzern also eine liste dessen mehr als zwanzig personen darauf die immer automatisch egal was der inhalt ist sofort immer in diese deckelung auto er nummer reinkam.
Okay.
Und wir haben dann kontakt aufgenommen halt mit auch einer person die da drauf ist dann wäre es ja was ist denn da los was ich wusste es gar nicht ey ich bin die sagt.
Bin dick und ich mach natürlich das auch aber ich habe ich habe gar kein problem damit wenn der gegenwind kommt was was was bildet sich eigentlich
ein mir irgendwie so parteiliste ich irgendwie zu sagen was ich denke für inhalte und mich da zu schützen kann mich schon selber schützen also wir haben konnten auch mit den leuten reden die betroffen sind
die sind alle ziemlich sauer und haben wir tiktok irgendwann konfrontiert,
ne also man wenn man das investigative recherche macht dann kommt irgendwann wenn man sich fertig recherchiert hat dann macht man so eine riesige latte von fragen und sagt,
stimmt es das stimmt es das ist es richtig das und sagt ihr habt zeit so und so viel zeit und dann bitte antworten,
und dann kam dann die antwort also wir wussten okay das ist im september noch,
gewesen und dann kam die antwort so da die regeln das ist
ganz alte sache das ist irgendwie früher temporär zu beginn einmal eingesetzt ja war interessant also die konfrontieren war auch immer so dass wir gefragt wo ist ist es richtig dass inhalte,
in ihre reichweite eingeschränkt werden
inhalt x in seiner reichweite eingeschränkt wird mit antwort war wir entfernen keine inhalte aus bereich x und immer solche über spezifischen antworten würde ja aber ich habe was anderes gefragt gefragt ob ich reichweite haben immer gesagt wir entfernen nicht wir werden nicht wimpern nichts was immer die standard antwort
ja genau das waren so die die haupt äh punkte der recherche ne also es war.
Ich fand 's spannend eben wie dieses wie wie wieso,
zensur inhalts kontrollen mechanismen der zukunft aussehen kann man da ganz gut sehen weil du wirst dich auch nicht dagegen wehren können du merkst irgendwie gar nicht und wird dann auch erzählt von der von der quelle das,
die leute dann merken ah okay das läuft nicht so gute probiere ich mal was anderes und so dass man leitet die leute dann auch von themen weg und auch das thema geht da irgendwie nicht
kein aber es ist halt nicht so dass es niemand interessiert sondern es das ticktack will nicht dass es jemand interessiert das ist halt schon ich.
Das ist eine konform pressung sozusagen man wird man wird einfach in so einen kanal reingeschoben mit verhalte dich mal lieber anders als du eigentlich wäre es dann dann dann wirst du auch akzeptiert und du kannst es dann hier in so einer zahl.
Ja ja.
Ablesen und ich meine ich kenne ja auch also bei youtube gibt's hervorragende kanäle die,
von leuten quartiert und gemacht werden die jetzt mit diesen tiktok regeln unter garantie vollständig in konflikt liegen würden ja vielleicht mal an der stelle auch mal 'ne empfehlung lars fischer
wir werden alle sterben der youtube-kanal ist einfach bombastisch gut so aber,
so mit seiner erscheinung würde er auf jeden fall bei tiktok komplett gegen die wand fahren.
Also zumindest nach dem früheren regeln.
Ja gut was weiß ich was die jetzt für regeln haben und wie sie dir jetzt anders nennen und so das das ist ja auch das ding du siehst es halt nicht du kannst es gar nicht messen so ist es.
Was ich ganz spannend finde ist dass wir in der letzten sendung ja schon kurz nur über das thema über das video von ferrero salsa siehst gesprochen die mit dem augen wimpern verlängern da anfängt und.
Top media guerilla aktion.
Als ich als ich das gelesen habe habe ich gedacht ach ja okay die ist jetzt irgendwie durchgekommen oder dass das ihr video wie sie's angesetzt hat im prinzip nur ein heck der sehgewohnheiten der menschen war,
aber so wie du jetzt die moderat die content moderation beschrieben hast war das egal ob beabsichtigt oder nicht ja vor allem ein heck.
Die nur gezeigt werden und die hunde ton nicht ja ja.
Weil den leuten nur friends geschickt werden und die leute die moderatoren halt oder die sensoren halt sagen ah ja hier pipi macht mal wieder ihre wimpern länger prima zack gibt next so sieht gut aus keine behinderung dran,
down-syndrom gib ihm ja und dann,
die redet über politik so hoch und dann ist es ja irgendwie offline gegangen und dann irgendwann wieder nicht weil die empörung groß war weil sie schon irgendwie sechzigtausend news hatte das heißt da das war ein ganz klassischer fall von da war der zensur pinkeln,
oder da hatte der zensur.
Oder das system kann das nicht hören den in barcelona hören die den ton nur auf da muss ich besser reinschauen die hören den ton nicht die sehen ein paar fremdes und dann entscheiden die und dann
bei dem video sehen sie nur ein mädchen mit wimpern zange ist da ne.
Das heißt was wir jetzt eigentlich machen müssen wir müssen uns alle tiktok account klicken und eine wimpern zange holen.
Genau oder irgendwas.
Anfange tim ich hätte da ein paar tipps für dich hast dir kann man richtig was machen.
Meister ich komme nochmal richtig groß raus.
Ich habe mir mal ein bisschen gel und eine und eine wimpern zange und 'n nasen haas ihrer und dann machen wir schöne tiktok wie.
Da ist,
aber ich weiß nicht was man hat was das problem generell bei diesem ganzen moderation zu regeln und inhalt kontrolle auf sozialen netzwerken ist ist man hat eigentlich kein einblick bis ich ein bissel blauer findet der irgendwie,
und journalisten die das dann aufarbeiten und wir müssen uns halt irgendwie schon fragen als
demokratische gesellschaften ey wie wollen wir eigentlich unternehmen beikommen die irgendwie
fundamentale regeln und standards von meinungsfreiheit oder verbot von diskriminierung etcetera was da alles,
verletzt wurde wie wir wie wir das eigentlich überhaupt merken und wie wir uns dagegen wehren wie wir das kontrollieren,
rennt machen können und wie man es reguliert ne also ich fasse es so
das ist schon krass also man will also ich persönlich bin nicht in einer welt leben in der die,
netzwerke die große öffentlichkeiten kontrollieren oder große öffentlichkeiten bieten und relevante öffentlichkeiten kontrollieren quasi
standards meinungsfreiheit standards aus china transportieren also das ist so.
Das ist ja vor allem also diese die wirkung von solchen entscheidungen die geht dir,
weit darüber hinaus was jetzt irgendwie das,
unternehmen macht etwas ja sondern diese sozialen netzwerke schaffen realitäten,
für menschen in diesen realitäten verbringen menschen.
Zweiundfünfzig minuten am tag bei uns halt dich dich dich gehört hatte.
So da in den zweiundfünfzig minuten bin ich als null minuten seit mehreren monaten ja mit einberechnet ja das heißt.
Ne das ist die leute die es nutzen.
Ja die leute das nutzen okay aber,
wenn ich hier im richtet sich ja glaube ich primär auch an teenager also ich hab,
den eindruck dass das junge menschen primär benutzen das ist der grund warum ich das habe ich muss das haben,
ne um einer einer tochter eines freundes die brauchte follower und die hat gesagt so hier mit dir rede ich nicht so lange du nicht beim tiktok kanal folgst ja nämlich gesagt boah hab ich jetzt keine zeit für handy her
zack und jetzt musste ich die nutzer werden und folge jetzt ja.
Ich glaube vielleicht ist es auch.
Ganz kurz in die in diesen in diesen,
was die menschen da sind das ist ja das fenster zur welt ja das ist ja das was was wir dort sehen ist wenn er jetzt menschen mit behinderungen auftauchen dann erkennen wird
das an dass das ein teil der realität ist der normal ist und wenn wir dann mit menschen mit behinderungen im normalen leben leben dann sehen wir aha,
sind normale menschen so und genauso ist es mit
ausländischen personen genauso ist das mit politischen positionen je mehr wir davon sehen und in unserem ganz normalen leben umso normaler wird das für uns der begriff der normalisierung und irgendwie auch
normalisierung der sich dann eben in solchen ganz fein granulat regeln irgendwie abbildet und das ist.
Sehr sehr sehr gefährlich das geht weit darüber hinaus jetzt zu sagen dieses unternehmen ist ist okay oder nicht okay sondern es geht wirklich finde ich an die fundamentale frage
dieses unternehmen kann letztendlich willkürlich die realität von menschen bestimmen und so ein teenager ist was weiß ich
zwölf bis vierzehn stunden am tag wache ein paar stunden davon in der schule also nur halb wach und dann ist diese wahrnehmung tiktok,
mit zweiundfünfzig durchschnitts minuten die du jetzt zitiert
signifikante anteil der wahrnehmung und wenn die nämlich nicht auf tiktok sind dann sitzt denn randy irgendwo auf der straße rum und unterhalten sich darüber oder über irgendwelche youtuber
und das ist letztendlich prägend finne für generationen und für millionen von menschen was die da sehen.
Was ich alles in spannenden aspekt finde ich meine diese erfolg dieser plattform hängt ja auch,
mit diesem harmonischen lustigen unbeschwerter also es gibt ja eine sehnsucht in der gesellschaft nur noch bei jungen leuten ich glaube auch nicht dass nur der junge sind aber nach so einem
ey ich will nicht twitter und es gibt immer auf die fresse du schreibst du hast uns kommt der trolle nazi dich irgendwie von der seite an irgendwie,
sondern dass leute sagen ok das ist irgendwas nettes lustiges du nicht nicht dieses aufgeladen politisch kontrovers und so immer also das muss man im hinterkopf haben dass menschen auch,
diese sehnsucht danach haben mal nicht irgendwie das zu haben,
nicht sie nicht die kontroverse aber das kann nicht sein dass das unseren alltag dass das ding ausgeschlossen werden halten und
gebremst also aber das das würde ich da würde ich gerne mal was drüber lesen bevor das eigentlich herkommt dass man dieses diese sehnsucht ort des konflikt freien harmonischen netzwerkes irgendwie also das.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen der also das ist die andere frage ne also,
twitter kann man auf jeden fall als das soziale netzwerk bezeichnen was ich jetzt am allerwenigsten,
darum bemüht seine inhalte irgendwie zu kontrollieren mit,
also wo das das letztendlich die andere kritik bekommt ja die die werden,
wenn ihr jetzt das tiktok kann sich hinstellen und sagen ey ihr wir wollten es besser machen als twitter,
und twitter kann sagen hier wir wollen noch nicht so ein ticket haben ne du sau hurensohn ich mach dich fertig menschen in not menschen pipapo.
Donald trump hätte auf tiptop auf jeden fall kein erfolg.
Donald trump hatte auf dich ja eine ganze menge leute werden oft nicht und das wär wobei ehrlich gesagt donald trump.
Weiter geht auf tiptop.
Der würde auch auf tiktok abgehen und da da hat man ja auch schon mal darüber gesprochen weil ja die,
also twitter sagt ja donald trump klar verstößt gegen unsere regeln am laufenden band,
aber es ist eine person des öffentlichen interesses und deswegen werden wir den durchgehen lassen was er will allein schon um historische archivierung zwecke ja was auch wiederum eine argumentation ist die,
die ich verstehen kann es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so als könnte man sagen ey ihr dürft donald trump keine plattform bieten ja ich weiß der präsident so was willst du jetzt machen kannst jetzt ist jetzt nicht so als könnte man den tod schweigen und weg moderieren wenn er irgendwo.
Profit.
Ich meine es wäre schön ja wenn ihr wie beim ankommt und also ne not for now for public gibt mikrofon aussieht zack zack zack nix das wäre natürlich eigentlich ganz,
also ich ich will nur damit sagen dass wir hier in einem bereich sind der,
enorme enorme wirkung auf auf das auf das leben von menschen auf unsere gesellschaft hat dass wir,
sowohl eine vollständige content nicht moderation als auch letztendlich jeden ansatz der content moderation scheiße finden und dass es irgendwie etwas damit,
zu tun hat und das scheint mir das zu grunde liegende problem zu sein dass diese unternehmen in diesen entscheidungen eben wirtschaftlich getrieben sind,
und nicht irgendwie.
Na aber die sind nicht nur wird also ich glaube das halten unten das unternehmen was in china sitzt muss halt den chinesischen regeln ist es unterworfen und gesetzen und natürlich wieder was,
exportiert mit ne und das ist halt jetzt neue das haben wir jetzt erst also dass das jetzt irgendwie auf einmal da was kommt was von der von der von der,
kommt nochmal eine andere sicht auf meinungsfreiheit nämlich eine sehr einschränken der sich durch meinungsfreiheit hat ja.
Ich fühl mich dabei die ganze zeit erinnert an haben einen vortrag den ich vor,
sechs jahren einmal gehalten habe mit dem,
rollt russel den habe ich auf der republika gehalten,
zusammen mit michael kreisel und er lehmann wohl mich letztendlich genau darüber gesprochen habe ja den also ich meine ich habe,
ich bin da weiter gegangen hab es ging darum den leuten den spaß auch an der plattform zu nehmen,
kann ich kann ich hier an der stelle mal kurz empfehlen aber wer werdet ihr viele dieser mechanismen wiedersehen also das was da nicht passiert ist eigentlich dieses sogenannte shadow opening oder,
herr bading dass man eben sagt okay pass auf ihr kriegt den eindruck dort statt zu finden ihr merkt auch nicht dass wir euch,
mit hintergründe mechanismen irgendwie limitieren,
und dadurch sorgen wir hier insgesamt für bestimmte,
ich will also der begriff standards ist natürlich der falsche aber das letztendlich sind es standards ne die da gesetzt werden.
Das widerspricht halt also fundamental einer rechtsstaatlichen auffassung von ich werde für irgendwas,
bestraft und da möchte ich nachvollziehbar sehen warum
passiert ist wie kann ich mich dagegen wehren stimmt es überhaupt gibt es irgendein institut instanz in dich gehen kann sagen hey hallo
und das wird natürlich interessant ich meine das ist ein unterschied jetzt wenn man jetzt wird netzwerk wird sagt wir müssen da eine regel einführen dass wenn was gelöscht ist es wieder hergestellt wird,
wie mach ich das denn bei tiktok ja das muss ich möchte recht auf generell feed oder recht auf
in der suche ganz gut dazu steht also das ist interessant weil es so filigran wird wie kann ich mich denn wehren also ich finde dieses sich nicht wehren können ist,
ist ein ding das das dürfen wir nicht einziehen lassen
das ist ja schon eingezogen aber da muss man gucken da muss ein andere wort drauf gefunden werden dass ich nicht einfach da steht sagt okay mein account ist weg,
mein video wird nie angeschaut von leuten oder also ich muss mich wehren kann und dem widersprechen alle plattformen und tiktok jetzt halt eben ganz besonders ich meine,
gibt es bei den anderen plattformen auch sehr gibt's ja auch quasi drosselten de und pushen die elemente mit communications bei bei youtube und et cetera.
Das erinnert mich vor allem an diese also wenn man über meinungsfreiheit diskutiert wird,
wenn wird häufig so ein,
satz gesagt wie du hast die das recht seine meinung zu äußern,
aber du hast kein recht darauf dass die leute dir zuhören,
und dich deine meinung teilen müssen und das jetzt wenn man das mal wenn das jetzt tiktok sagen würde dann ist es ja schon relativ.
Das ist eine sache finde und da gibt's leider viel zu wenig,
arbeiten gute konzepte et cetera drüber ist wie gehen wir mit plattform um
die eine relevante oder mark dominante größe erreicht haben und die öffentlichkeit konstituieren die eben so groß ist dass ich nicht mehr sagen kann hey sorry privatunternehmen wir machen hier was wir wollen sondern
wo wo es eben relevant wird dass leute gar nicht mehr durchdringen können,
das eine ist natürlich sagen hey jeder kann seine meinung sagen aber du darfst also wie weit ist das,
ja ich meine wir haben das problem dass die ganze also die meinungsfreiheit schreien momentan irgendwie aus dem rechtsradikalen lager sind und mit meiner freiheit schreien irgendwie hetze hass und gewalt eigentlich meinen also,
das ist jetzt sehr polarisieren gesprochen aber es ist ein echtes problem natürlich nur wenn die gegner die eigentlichen gegner der meinungsfreiheit so tun als seien sie die befürworter da wird die diskussion halt schwierig.
Ja wie würdest du was würdest du fitter,
was würdest du tiktok jetzt empfehlen also sie haben ja jetzt erstaunlicherweise auch sitzt ja sie haben sich im prinzip aus jeder kritik zumindest in ihren äußerungen immer versucht zu winden ne.
Ja die haben schon einige also ich finde,
in der ersten konfrontiert drunk durchaus einige sachen auch individuelle fragen beantworte als journalist steht man ja irgendwie wenn man mit diesen plattformen redet schickst den fragen und es kommt irgendwie,
hallo die beste experience irgendwie also ich würde auch sagen kennt nach einer zeit ah das ist twitter das ist da also,
trägst immer nur quatsch ne das ist eine black box und dann gehst du hin und sagst du eigentlich,
der black box was gefunden das und das und das stimmt das und dann kriegst du so.
Irgend so ein so ein gewässer,
und wenn dann wird immer nur in on background geredet mit dir das ist auch so im prinzip von diesen plattformen also dass du sie niemals zitiert fähig,
irgendwie dann sagen die im hintergrund dir ein bisschen mehr du darfst es aber nicht richtig zitieren und am ende kannst du nicht die festnageln sagen facebook hat am siebzehnten september das und das gesagt sondern
du musst dann als journalist bist dann immer derjenige der es gesagt hat und das ist halt ein scheiß prinzip sondern und tiktok könnte jetzt wenn sie wenn sie cool wären,
in der kommunikation sie haben eine krisen kommunikations- agentur extra gebucht,
sie,
man könnte natürlich mal die messlatte anders aufhängen und sagen ja wir gehen jetzt transparent damit um wir zeigen mal wie die regeln sind und machen,
und gehen zeigen zeigen irgendwie auch ein stinker finger zu zu facebook die auch nie sagen wie sie es machen oder zu zu instagram oder zu twitter die irgendwie manchmal gar nicht antworten wenn man nachfragt also
das wäre eine chance ich glaube aber nicht dass plattform ja ich bin lass mich überraschen.
Es wäre halt ja was was müsstet was können sie tun also der zumindest.
Na ja ich weiß was sie tun werden ich vermute so,
dass sie sowas machen werden würde ich sagen wir haben
den chinesischen standort geschlossen jetzt wird von down da moderiert wir haben irgendwie die wir trennen das ab von einem chinesischen,
markt irgendwie also dass sie quasi sich von diesem ganzen china vorwürfen
hier in den usa noch weitergehen mit security streets und so dass sie sich davon so lösen um um das wegzubekommen
ne also dass du das machen denke ich das wird auf jeden fall,
jetzt der umstrukturierung geben das hatten wir auch soweit irgendwie auch schon so ein bisschen angekündigt.
Jetzt müssen wir noch ein bisschen darüber schreiben ja du hast das ist jetzt dein,
international am meisten wieder wahrgenommenen artikel interessanterweise artikel die netzwerk org,
geschrieben hat die haben national sehr viel mehr aufmerksamkeit bekommt ne.
Ja es gibt so wirklich unterschied also es ist interessant auch so so wie so 'ne interessen stinger durch router zwang das ist so ein top-thema ganz super netzwerke schreiben klickt sich wie sau viele kommentare gibt 's andere themen die laufen wie das jetzt.
Ich will kein roter jetzt wollte ich wollte mich jetzt mit dem roten.
Wir haben uns echt also der das ist schon schon spannend wie also manche themen gehen halt so sowas hier,
deutschlandweit irgendwie super gut und das thema wald ich glaube einfach weil halt wenige leute da sind war jetzt nicht so groß auf netz politiker selber.
Muss man dazu sagen es ist ja nicht so dass ihr alle artikel auch auf englisch publizieren würden ne also was ist da überhaupt erst rausholt dafür dass ihr irgendwas in.
Genau wir sind denn da eigentlich eure moderation regeln dann wird's denn auf erde.
Verdrängt dir vielleicht bestimmte themen einfach aus dem internationalen feed.
Wenn wir den featured button also international feature auto auto,
auto international einsetzen dann sind wir,
dass die themen irgendwie international gut gehen könnten und bei tiktok was da auch gerade ein zeitfenster glaube ich wo.
Woran merkt ihr das.
Na wir lesen internationale medien in der regel also viel amerikanische sachen und also merkt hat.
Aber es ist nicht so dass jetzt erst mal jemand den deutschen artikel aufgreift in einem internationalen medium und dann sagt er jetzt machen wir das auch mal auf englisch.
Nee du bist gleich direkt alle auf englisch übersetzt also weil wir dachten so okay das ist jetzt also das ist ja auch 'ne recherche hat viel zeit gekostet und ist irgendwie schon gemerkt okay wir haben dann ist auch irgendwie hat das pulver.
Das muss man auch mal ordentlich monetarisieren werden.
Ein monetarisieren ja hey die spenden kampagne begonnen muss ich noch sagen nee nee das das hat einfach das so gerochen als würde das international,
irgendwie interesse wecken ne und dann machen wir schon immer wieder sachen gerade wenn die so exklusiv sind und so,
dass wir da versuchen weil es ist natürlich schon die englischen artikel haben auch echt viel reichweite bekommen und,
ist halt auch mehr menschen das lesen können aber wir können natürlich dort ziemlich jedes mal englische artikel machen wäre schon auch geil aber.
Aber als er ist klar dass sie nicht jede ist immer meldung auf englisch macht aber dann hat die recherchen oder.
Macht ihr denn die übersetzung in haus also habt ihr leute oder gib dir das raus.
In china.
Wir haben ja keine kohle für übersetzer zahlt nee wir haben ein paar muttersprachler und,
wir haben äh und dann machen wir so eine mischung daraus und dann werden die schlimmsten dinge,
also das man merkt dass der text wahrscheinlich auch manchmal anders sie.
Algorithmus erstellt sind.
Der erste text ist nicht ist nicht computer rasiert übersetzt worden aber klar ist natürlich immer wieder aufwand da brauchst du auch jemand und ein texte also kommt doch wieder kohle,
ja aber.
Ja du kannst es jetzt auch nochmal erwähnen also ja wie alle nutze die weihnachtszeit.
Genau weil wir alles genau wer.
Ey keine werbung für andere plattformen hier.
Ach ist das ist ja so keine scheiße nordhoff it,
schaut mal schaut mal drauf wir haben auch.
Also wir können jetzt drüber reden aber das landet dann nicht.
Wenn alles leise gedreht so ganz leise.
Musik kommt ein schönes lied.
Nee also jetzt muss ich schon sagen ich bin solche sachen,
macht unglaublich spaß sowas zu machen es kostet unglaublich viel zeit aber es ist halt auch geil dass es möglich ist und das machen eben die ganzen spenderinnen und spender mit ihren geldern möglich dass man irgendwie so nah,
inhalts kontroll zensur plattform auch mal auf die finger schauen kann und es macht natürlich auch die,
quelle möglich die sich die wir da hatten ne das muss man auch in so einem fall immer wieder sagen,
gehört immer eben auch jemand dazu der oder die da,
auch die nachrichten weitergibt.
Die abteilung hat wieder zugeschlagen.
Okay damit hat das was unser kurzes video von tiptop.
Ich würde sagen ja das was.
Ein sternchen und folgt.
Genau und schaut mal vorbei wir haben nämlich eine neue idee mit so einem art netzwerk netz politik äh und startet heute.
Aha netzwerk netzwerk.
Es ist noch nicht ist noch nicht online.
Aber wenn man nicht wenn man netzwerk netz politik googelt kommt man schon zu netzwerk netzwerk netzwerk,
ne ich weiß ok also ihr habt eine neue eine neue drucker kolonnen idee und da kann man jetzt kriegt man was was was kriegt man im netzwerk in der kritik,
ja komm bisschen sein hier.
Drauf schauen das ist die idee ist die leute wir haben irgendwie mehrere tausend menschen die uns regelmäßig unterstützen und das
geht davon quasi ich komm vorbei bring euch eine schokolade oder es kommt ein brief oder absender mit einem huni drin
bis zu spenden euch einfach mal sowas und es gibt aber leute die regelmäßig drei euro spenden oder vier euro zwanzig oder keine ahnung und wir
die idee dahinter ist die mal näher ran zu holen aber auch dann
sachen zu machen und man nachzufragen ey was sollen wir eigentlich für also wir wollen das auch ein bisschen ausbauen in,
wo man ey was soll das man die auch einbildet die leute die dann im netzwerk sind mal bei
was thematisch interessiert weil wir wissen ganz wenig,
was diese leute werden von sechzigtausend am tag gelesen aber viertausend spenden und sowas würde gerne mal wissen was du eigentlich die die die uns wirklich was wert ist was die auch,
eigentlich erwarten und so na das ist ja immer so.
Ihr wollt endlich meine community aufbauen hab ich ja schon vor jahren gesagt ja ja.
Wurde uns von allen immer herangetragen und jetzt haben wir es endlich geschafft.
Jetzt konntet euch ihn nicht mehr wären ja.
Nee ich glaube ich glaube es ist freuen uns alle was gucken zu gucken was da passiert und genau schaut mal vorbei.
Alles klar ja auch unserer community kann man unterstützen aber.
Netzwerk lok politik.
Aber ich bin ja nicht so der fan,
von den ewigen hinweisen darauf,
wir werden das auch jetzt mal langsam einführen einfach weil man glaube ich als podcast nicht mehr ernst genommen wird ohne lange.
Die ganze zeit nach geld schreibt.
Wenn man nicht die ganze zeit nach geldbeutel ja dann fragen die einen halb fragen sich die hörer wahrscheinlich meint denn nicht das ist das haben die haben sich schon genug geld oder was aber wir kommen wir kommen.
Nein es ist aber auch ich fand das ist das ist auch okay.
Ja ist okay.
Die sachen auch nur weil leute.
Ich denke es stellt auch einen wert da wenn man jetzt die leute auch nicht die ganze zeit mit diesen sachen terrorisiert furchtbar finde ich das.
Ja das finde ich auch also ich klicke auch ungern weg.
Wir kommen.
Und wir fordern euch auch nicht auf uns irgendwie bei itunes mit likes und sternchen zu versorgen und was wir alles.
Aber das ergebnis.
Aber ihr könnt schon mal fünf sterne der lok buchen jetzt politik auf itunes geben.
Ja also ihr könnt.
Damit ihr ein bisschen höher im feed gerankt werden.
Als dankeschön dafür dass wir euch nicht den ganzen tag voll ballern,
irgendwelche scheiße wenn ihr noch liken und empfehlen soll könntet ihr uns einfach mal bei itunes ein sternchen gehen.
Eins.
Und die könnte und ihr könnt.
Eine empfehlung schreiben ja na schön das ist gut das hilft und uns anderen leuten empfehlen das könnt ihr einfach mal machen und ihr könnt einfach sagen,
hey liebe freunde ich mag logbuch netzwerk weil da wird man nicht dazu gezwungen die ganze zeit das einen freund zu empfehlen.
Ja ich spende doch ein logbuch netz politik.
Komm wir kommen nach kommen wir nach russland.
Endlich.
Nach russland so russland hat sich überlegt,
wenn wenn bei uns hier sachen verkauft werden zum beispiel so ein iphone dann hätten wir das eigentlich ganz gerne,
dass wir bestimmte apps vor installiert hätten,
bei bei geräten die in unserem land verkauft werden und das ist eine,
gängige praxis von unternehmen von unternehmen das zu tun ja wenn du ein smartphone,
kaufst was subventioniert wird.
Von der bildzeitung zum beispiel gab's.
Von der ist der ist ja oder wenn es.
Dann möchte sie oder kriegst du sie auch immer wieder kommt ich hab dir 'ne basis wieder bildzeitung da zum glück nicht bei dem.
Hat ihr bild von in der redaktion oder was.
Ne das war bei früher irgendwo bei dem handy.
Klassiker ne du kaufst du kaufst ein samsung telefon dann sind da irgendwelche samsung apps drauf du kaufst,
telekom telefon früher zumindest bei den feature vor uns oder so in der war der wo davon,
irgendwo davon kram auf dem vodafone telefon und irgendeine telekom sache auf dem telekom von manchmal haben sie auch noch ein aufkleber drauf gemacht ne dass da irgendwo davon auf dem auf dem motoroller razer gelebte oder was auch immer ne also diese,
taktik wird verfolgt und es wird auch beispielsweise in,
kenne ich diese praxis ja auch von mobilfunkanbieter die gerade in sogenannten entwicklungsländern,
im prinzip eine digitalisierung vorantreiben dass sie sagen naja okay wir bauen mobilfunknetz bei uns gibt's nur die telefone dazu die wir
verteilen und auf diesem telefon sind unsere apps für was weiß ich soziales netzwerk cloud,
streaming vorinstalliert weil wir kein bock haben dass wir dieses mobilfunknetz bauen das andere damit reibach machen.
Oder halt apps anderer hersteller die dafür.
Die sich da rein gekauft hab ich gesagt ne also das das gibt es und das ist schon ohnehin.
Unsinn.
Eine unsinn ja ich will es es ist die dürfen das aber ist eine unsinn wir wollen das.
Schönes wort unsinn.
Unsinn unsinnig es ist unsinnig es es ist unwirklich.
Für die us experiences und.
Wir machen es noch den den nutzern nur leicht da müssen sie es nicht mehr von hand installieren.
Ist einfach besser wenn man vor als erlebte apps hat also.
Genau ne sonst müsstest du die runterladen geht direkt von dem datenvolumen.
Nur so hast du korrekt ist nur so hast du korrektes ups.
Außerdem ist ja auch die frage sondern wenn du jetzt in deutschland ein smartphone kaufen und da sind keine apps installiert wie willst du denn runterladen wenn in einem der.
Musste ja immer in urlaub fahren offene netz insel und gut jetzt russland hat gesagt okay offizielle begründung,
wir möchten den russischen it-unternehmen eine höhere wettbewerbsfähig gegen,
fähigkeit gegenüber ihren ausländischen konkurrenten ermöglichen deswegen machen wir jetzt ein gesetz das tritt am ersten juli zwanzig zwanzig offiziell in kraft und da wird
bestimmte russische software
vorinstalliert ausgestattet vorinstalliert sein müssen wenn ein smartphone tablet computer oder smart-tv in der,
russischen föderation vertrieben werden soll,
und das dann müssten die kunden eben diese vorinstalliert den russischen es nicht mehr herunterladen und damit wird,
denen nahegelegt ne diese apps doch auch mal auszuprobieren und informelle wird das bezeichnet als das gesetz gegen apple ja weil es damit,
apple finde ich da noch nicht mal die primäre,
instanz google wäre eigentlich das größere problem also apple hat ja jetzt sowieso nichts vor installiert was jetzt in die dicken
in das dicke business geht also ich meine facebook ist nicht vorinstalliert twitter ist nicht vor installiert tiktok ist nicht vorinstalliert.
Aber die google google ist nach wie vor die in der suche.
Das weiß ich zum beispiel nicht ob das in den usa auch so in den in der in der in der russischen föderation so ist könnte sein.
Das ist eine gute frage das weiß ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht genau weil ich.
Jan decks ist die russische suchmaschine ne.
Ja die ist vielleicht aus wählbar keine ahnung muss mal kurz.
Aber.
Aber apple lässt sich ja sonst auch staatlich rein reinreden oder,
apple lässt sich ja staatlich schon auch reinreden.
Interessant hat interessanterweise und das ist genau das thema jetzt sagt an die russen also dieses gesetz beschlossen,
und sagen so strafe zweihunderttausend rubel pro verkauften gerät,
das viel sind zwei zweitausendachthundert euro teurer als jedes iphone was du was sie sich bisher getraut haben auf den markt zu bringen und,
apple hat jetzt gesagt na ja passt auf das ist,
da haben wir keinen bock drauf da werden wir unter umständen unser geschäftsmodell in russland überarbeiten oder das land ganz verlassen wenn ihr dieses gesetz macht und
finde ich interessant dass apple jetzt da das unternehmen ist was die was die fahne hoch hält weil ich er erwartet hätte das samsung google sagen,
andererseits scheint es so zu sein dass.
Kurzer hinweis sieht so aus als ob tatsächlich index die vollzeit in russland ist es war zumindest eine änderung diesmal gab ich weiß nicht ob die zurückgenommen wurde.
Okay würde ich von also,
würde mich nicht wundern weil was wahrscheinlich in bestimmten gerade in in russland wahrscheinlich andechs einfach die besseren suchergebnisse,
liefert und ich weiß nicht ob apple die die die positionierung als die vollzeit engin auch verkauft.
Oh ja oh ja das ist eine haupteingang quelle für.
Eine haupteingang quelle für apple das hat ja aber.
Ja ja es handelt sich da um milliarde.
Das ist eine haupteingang quelle für firefox aber doch nicht für apple.
Doch apple nimmt extrem ich kann die zeit nicht genau als es eher im milliarden bereich angesiedelt also es ist natürlich keine offiziell bestätigte zahl von daher mit vorsicht zu genießen aber,
apple lässt sich das bezahlen.
Okay aber selbst wenn es im milliarden bereich wäre es keine haupteingang quelle weil apple setzt zwei hundertsechzig milliarden.
Ja ja also ich würde sagen alles was milliarden einbringt vor allem ich meine.
Ab einer milliarde kriegst in key account manager bei apple hast 'ne telefonnummer kannst du geschäftszeiten anrufen geht einer dran.
Muss halt auch mal sehen wie wie viel wie viel arbeit sie das kostet diese dienstleistung anzubringen also das ist.
Auf jeden fall profit center okay.
Das auf jeden fall keine frage trotzdem ist apple jetzt nicht glücklich mit diesem vorstoß.
Nee er hat gesagt als klar vor dem beabsichtigen wir uns nicht zu
zufügen und brot jetzt quasi gegen dieses gesetz und interesse interessant ist
bei den diskussionen mit china ob jetzt die hongkong live map im app store ist oder nicht da hat apple sich dann wiederum anders verhalten und jetzt ist die frage.
Das ist aber ein anderer.
Mars.
Fall ja es ist was anderes.
Ist das so wenn das so ist dann dann wäre das das was ich mit euch diskutieren möchte.
Also es hat nicht vorinstalliert also die hongkong live map diese protest.
Warum nicht ich will die haben.
Na ja nee aber ich muss mal was ist das ist so 'ne app burg ich kann markieren die polizei ist da und da hier ist das und das hier ist demo und so eine eine eine organisation app für revolte.
Wir haben ja auch schon drüber gesprochen,
ich weiß nicht ob der vergleich jetzt zieht weil natürlich diese app ja noch nicht mal eine richtige app war sondern eigentlich auch nur so ein webbrowser rapper und du kannst es danach immer noch genauso elegant auf dein telefon installieren einfach als vorhin cellulite webseite.
Aber sie haben's rausgenommen.
Sie haben's dann rausgenommen wobei das ja auch schon hin und her war sie haben's rausgenommen ich vermute erstmal auf basis einer normalen prüfung mit
eure app ist ja gar keine richtige app sondern nur ein rapper um eine webseite und das ist ein kriterium um
rauszuschmeißen dadurch ist es wahrscheinlich ausgelöst worden da gab es proteste haben's wieder reingenommen dann ist china ist darauf aufmerksam geworden glaube ich und dann haben sie das quasi genutzt als auch als hebel um apple da mal ein reinzufinden und dann waren sie quasi gefangener ihrer eigenen maßnahme,
die installation heißt ja beim iphone ist teil des betriebssysteme so 'ne funktionalität mit du ins
verlierst dein system und dann lädt sie automatisch irgendwie apps runter zu den du nicht explizit ja gesagt hast dir dann auch teil deines accounts und es hat einfach komplikationen security rechte im publikation
und generell will natürlich apple überhaupt niemanden bevorzugen weil das bedeutet ja auch dass sie die sich gegenüber allen anderen dann auch.
Könnte jeder kommen.
Ja da könnte dann dann dann kommt dann auch jeder und dann sind sie da halt auch in einer schlechten diskussion.
Was für app sollen das sind sein solltest nur darum gehen dass da.
Das ist.
Vkontakte irgendwie schon vorinstalliert ist oder soll da noch die die efb putin.
Das ist halt das nächste ding ne wenn das erstmal drin ist und akzeptiert ist dann kann ja im prinzip russland sagen ja heute machen wir noch mal das und das und das und das und dann hast du ein iphone mit fünf seiten äußern rascher da drin,
also dass sie das nicht geil finde.
Staatliche apps immer wieder jeder sagen ey
auf gar keinen fall also wenn es hier die bundesregierung sagen würde ja auf ihrem iphone auf ihrem ding wird jetzt hier die bundesregierung und links jetzt können sie auch hier straftaten melden und eng und so ein bisschen so 'ne app bei dir drauf,
berechtigung kontakte auslesen staatsapparates will jetzt also leute im vorsichtig.
Die idee könnte deutschland auch jemand kommen soll ja wir brauchen jetzt hier die wenn was nicht stimmt der polizei.
Also was es was ich daran interessant finde ist ich werde,
wo wollen wir die hoheit haben über solche entscheidungen also in dem heise hat darüber berichtet die haben auch so ein pro kontra und da werden jetzt andere fälle wo sich,
apple lokalen,
gesetzen oder anforderungen angepasst hat werden zum beispiel genannt die flagge von taiwan und hongkong gibt es in china nicht ne.
Also es gibt keine eingabe an kein eingabe interface dafür.
Ja die ist halt aus den emojis weg ist einfach der.
Ist schon noch da also anzeigen kannst du es aber.
Genau du kannst dir nicht.
Die eingabe funktion du kannst nicht auswählen in der tastatur.
Ja das heißt letztendlich wird eine wird eine wird eine tasse taste auf der tastatur ist bei apple jetzt auch nichts neues es gibt haste fehlt ja auch,
ganz kurz die beispiele noch zu nennen in in bestimmten
ländern wie saudi-arabien und dubai haben sie bestimmte dienste gesperrt auf japanischen vor uns haben sie automatisch den foto auslöser an
also in in japan wollen die wollen die heimliche fotografieren dadurch verhindern dass das telefon einfach immer dieses geräusch macht,
und dann wo es auch viel ärger gab ist halt oder,
sehr sehr häufige diskussion ist welche welche gebiete sind auf karten eingezeichnet.
Das ist ein generell ein riesenproblem weil über länder da alle mega empfindlich sind und.
Weil es unterschiedliche auffassungen gibt ob länder wie die quer in krim oder die krim gehört westjordanland.
Oder westjordanland das ist ja auch schon immer so.
Also da ist das,
bei ländern so dass google zeigt immer die wenn du wenn ich jetzt aus irgendeinem land raus mir die karte anschaue dann zeigt die das was der staat aus dem ich das anschaue als sein land beansprucht damit kein problem gibt.
Was ja auch was gewissermaßen ja also man könnte argumentieren die hohe halt liegt beim start,
über die gesetze und den hat sich dann halt das unternehmen unterzuordnen wenn wir über wenn wir über andere sachen,
sprechen dann erwarten wir das ja auch wenn wir eine cd dsgvo,
machen dann erwarten wir auch dass google sagt alles klar sehen wir ein,
und jetzt sagt jetzt sagt russland hier vor installiert,
hast du dich gesehen punkt ruhr und dann sollen sie es auf einmal nicht machen und also ich finde das ein
ich finde es ist ein schwieriges feld so ist es schwierig zu sagen zu applaudieren halte ich nicht an die gesetze andererseits sind diese gesetze halt verrückt,
und apple sind die oder diese großen konzerne sind die einzigen die in der lage wären sich
denen zu widersetzen und dann macht ihre macht zu nutzen um gegen verrückte gesetze anzugehen und das ein oder andere mal könnten wir das wahrscheinlich auch in deutschland noch mal gebrauchen dass irgendwie apple und google sagen.
Verschlüsselung unsere sachen also da also ich finde es erstmal ganz gut sich das abzuwehren.
Okay,
sich spontan finde ich das auch ich finde es auch gut wenn sie hier diese alte diskussion ist ja auch hier apple gegen wo das fbi das apple zwingen wollte hier baut,
manipuliert ein telefon dass es unsicherer ist damit wir es hier mit zelebriert knacken können und apple hat gesagt nee,
geht nicht und also das sind spannende diskussionen ich frag mich nur werden wir dir immer nur einzelfall basiert führen und dann am ende an unseren politischen glauben,
ausgelöst oder nicht.
Es hat die frage mit wem du es machen kannst das finde ich ja das ist ein bisschen so der vorwurf,
also heißt china ist halt genug da wird das iphone produziert die sind so mächtig und so wichtig und so groß dass niemand die fresse aufmacht und russland ist halt ja ist halt nicht so nicht so wichtig das,
da kann ich dir da kann ich mich wehren und das ist halt so ein bisschen schwierig man das,
muss man dann schon global durchziehen ne also so ein so ein ding.
Ja ich meine was wollen sie machen also in dem moment wo das gesetz ist so ist dann für sie die entscheidung,
bleiben wir auf dem markt oder nicht so und in gewisser hinsicht ist ihr,
haben sie glaube ich da ein ganz interessantes dro potenzial wir hatten das ja übrigens auch in indien wenn ich mich richtig erinnere als die was war das nochmal was wollen die einführen,
das waren irgendwie netz sperren oder ändert sich da noch dran irgendwas sollte in indien irgendwie eingeführt werden und.
Ganz menge eingeführt aber weißt du die.
Apple hat dann irgendwie gesagt na dann dann dann dann verkaufen wir kein i phone mehr und kannst du natürlich vorstellen wer iphones hat in indien so ja und so.
Ah du meinst das ist die das ist herr hebel indem man an die elite.
Ja apple apple will den parlamentariern irgendwie ihre iphones ihre statussymbol wegnehmen und das glaube ich auch in russland durchaus noch so ein aspekt,
das ist jetzt irgendwie gut oder einfach nur die die realität dass ich darüber ein hill haben aber machen wir uns nichts vor und man ist auch glaube ich allen klar das smartphone,
ist einfach mehr als,
ein interessantes gerät sondern es ist halt einfach in zunehmenden maße der träger unserer identität,
und damit ist es natürlich auch quasi das interface zum start und das interface zu dieser welt und die begehrlichkeiten werden da nicht zurückgefahren werden sondern dass das ist jetzt einfach nur der anfang.
Die nächste dekade soll doch schön werden habt ihr gesagt.
Ja zehn jahre pause bevor es dann wieder schlimm wird,
genau und diese begehrlichkeiten werden zunehmend,
so bis hin zu voller ständiger kontrolle darüber wie so ein gerät zu funktionieren hat,
dass es so eine diskussion war apps so neben dem deswegen finde ich das jetzt hier auch grade in diesem contra ding so ein bisschen so
was erlaube apple mir meine e-zigaretten app wegzunehmen was seid ihr denn für böse leute so,
sorry aber das das ist dann doch ein bisschen am am am thema vorbei ja weil erstmal zum leben braucht keine app.
Du
Ja und das.
Du willst doch die statistiken.
Essen ist halt ein gesundheits aspekte so und wenn halt irgendwie der staat gerechtfertigt oder nicht gesagt dass es halt irgendwie kritische bereich so dann kann man so eine entscheidung schon fällen das stimmt jetzt irgendwie kein erfahren klar ist alles im grenzbereich der der debatte,
das wird es immer sein wenn's um smartphones geht,
aber die nächsten schritte sind natürlich so wir wollen da mein netzwerk interface rein wir wollen einmal die firewall holst irgendwie auf deinem telefon vor definieren und das sind so die debatten auf die wir uns wahrscheinlich in den nächsten jahren einstellen dürfen,
insofern ist es gut das wollte ich dazu sagen dass sie da jetzt auch die muskeln die sie noch haben auch spielen lassen.
Google sollte das mama machen wir nicht.
So
dann wären wir beim nächsten und letzten thema betitelt mit windows zehn fressen daten auf ja die berliner polizei wurde von windows sieben auf windows zehn
aktualisiert,
ich glaube da sind sie noch herrschaft dabei weil windows sieben end of life ist glaube ich im januar oder hab ich das falsch in erinnerung
ich glaube einige windows version ja vierzehnter januar siebzehnte januar zwanzig zwanzig also die gute nachricht ist die berliner polizei hat ganz kurz vorm ende of life noch von windows sieben weg migriert,
schlechte nachricht ist dabei sind wichtige ermittler daten verloren gegangen denn,
die haben die mitarbeiter vorher nicht über die umstellung informiert,
und keine sicherheitskooperation der festplatten angelegt und dann einfach mal.
Niemals von update macht.
Mal so ein release update gemacht ja von version sieben unter umgehung von version,
auf version zehn was kann da schon schiefgehen,
ja was dabei schiefgehen kann ist alle daten weg aber deswegen macht man ja vorher ein backup und wenn du keins gemacht hast gilt halt kein backup kein mitleid.
Ich habe ich habe fragen also erstens wo bitte speichern die ihre ermittlungs daten.
Computer.
Wo löscht windows bei so einem update also wenn das wenn sie das so in dem system ordner
abgelegt haben oder so dann dann bin ich technisch jetzt nicht sonderlich überrascht ja dass da was wegkommt ist eher die frage wie wie wie wie konnte man da überhaupt was reinschreiben wenn es jetzt ganz normale benutzer ordner waren freue mich,
ich kann das wirklich sein dass so ein update diese daten löscht also da hab ich jetzt auch zu wenig informationen und das wirklich zu machen andererseits was
haben diese daten bitte auf den rechnern zu tun im jahr zwanzig neunzehn ist das nicht alles.
Robert.
Auf dem server und der da gesichert wird und war,
was ist mit der backup strategie also das ist doch hier im wesentlichen ein administrative fail also,
ja kann sein dass jetzt irgendeine untiefen in diesem upgrade prozess gibt aber ich glaube das,
ich hätte jetzt auch mit jedem anderen uss und die anderen administrativen standard maßnahme durchaus passieren können und wenn es da halt einfach kein backup gibt die sagen wir immer so schön kein backup kein mitleid
das haben wir jetzt an dieser stelle nicht auch wenn's sicherlich blöde sache ist dass ermittlungs daten verloren gehen.
Vielleicht ist er sich sehen sie unter wandert von der organisierten kriminalität die in den atmen und it strukturen oh nein verschwörungstheorie.
Jetzt neu auch bei bundespolitik ja wir haben gehört das geht gut auf dem markt.
Die neuesten verschwörungstheorien,
es gibt gut geld dann kann man mehr fünf sterne geben bei itunes.
Da brauchen wir auch noch einen single zu neben der guten nachricht gibt's jetzt auch noch die verschwörungstheorie der woche die wir einfach mal streuen.
Okay.
Klickt sich gut.
Klickt sich gut was ich hoffentlich auch gut klickt ist.
Ist halt bei podcast die sie gut klicken ist 'n bisschen schwierig richtig gut hört gar keine.
Unsere freunde von der digitalen gesellschaft schweiz haben eine kurze anleitung zur digitalen selbstverteidigung schon seit längerer zeit online und die haben sie nun,
mit der zusammen mit der whats und dem chaos computer club schweiz in der überarbeiteten dritten auflage heute veröffentlicht und als beilage zur whats nummer neunundvierzig,
in umlauf gebracht das ist auch sehr schön und das haben wir nochmal verlinkt und also gibt's natürlich auch als pdf,
und das finde ich immer sehr schön wenn sich da jemand zu viel,
mühe macht das mal alles zusammen zu fassen ich sehe gerade sie haben sogar noch werbung für netzwerk unten drin aber nicht für logbuch netzwerk.
Nochmal die whats.
Wochenzeitung glaube ich wieder.
Steht auch in diesem artikel nicht drin okay.
Und die wochenzeitung ja habe ich.
Ja das ist ein links liberales blatt in der schweiz.
Am netz politik empfohlen logbuch netz politik nicht.
Ja das ist dann so hat auch limone diplomatie in beilage und so ja okay verstehe habe ich mich wieder unwissen über den schweizerischen kulturraum geoutet.
So wir sind fertig.
Einfach so markus vielen dank.
Einfach so danke gerne.
Ja ihr könnt jetzt empfehlen.
Und ich bin noch ein bisschen.
Wir haben da echt mal also kann durchaus mal wieder empfohlen werden hier.
Ja linus linus will immer das feld das für empfohlen sind und.
Der mir blutet das aus den ohren dass es andere machen ich komme in diesem podcast so falsch vor weil wir nicht die ganze zeit um spenden wählen.
Drei punkte.
Nicht auf all diesen lippen plattformen vertreten sind wo uns irgendwie andere leute.
Was ihr seid nicht bei spotify also.
Tatsächlich ein problem ja seid ihr.
Ist natürlich bei spotify na also ja seitdem haben wir millionenpublikum nein ich habe keine ahnung ich habe.
Ich sehe das tatsächlich als problem ist also ich.
Wollt ihr die diskussion jetzt am ende aufmachen.
Ne ich sehe das also es ist es ist das problem von dem ich immer gewarnt habe aber es ist halt so die leute hören halt mit spotify und ich habe aber auch schon gelesen unter welchen bedingungen wir aus spotify dürften und dort,
darauf hinzuweisen dass über spotify zu abonnieren einfach unsinnig ist würde gegen die regeln verstoßen.
Verstanden.
Du kannst.
Man darf da nicht schlecht reden über sport.
Achso.
Regel von spotify spotify ja und damit haben wir natürlich bestimmte schwierigkeiten mit unserem podcast ich mein so ein so ein so ein sauber gewaschen des gefallen format wie euer.
Gemäß ja wir streaming.
In der sendung das geht natürlich klar aber.
Streaming haben wir gemacht wir haben uns da ein bisschen angepasst spotify also wirklich spotify super ne keine ahnung ich habe mir das noch nicht angeschaut hat ich ich höre nur.
Ja dann guck mal guck mal da guck mal bei den neuen podcast plattform die alle.
Der tobi bayer hat erzählt einschlafen podcast gut ich meine das natürlich auch keiner hin weil die leute ja einschlafen aber er hat halt der hat irgendwie die hälfte seiner hörerinnen bei spotify.
Na ja man muss immer dahin wo der bürger ist okay jetzt.
Ein schwieriges thema machen wir jetzt nicht mehr auf.
Wenn man den zahlen glauben darf.
Ja alles weiß ich jetzt auch nicht ist ja auch egal deswegen wollte ich diese diskussion mit tim zu führen ist.
Meine statistiken lieber.
Geh mal.
Sag mal so dass diese diskussion mit tim zu führen wer auf jeden fall unsere hörer zahlen nicht zuträglich deswegen empfehlt uns bei itunes.
Ich ich bin immer immer bereit diese diskussion zu führen ich führe die diskussion die für die diskussion auch mit mir selber so und ich sehe die probleme die da sind so und ich hab das auch kommen sehen ja dass das eben so ist,
wenn wir aber zumindest nicht vorwerfen lassen es ich derjenige bin der alle irgendwie erstmal in diese richtung getrieben hat so einfach um das mal,
rauszustellen na ja es ist so.
Aber ich stelle mir vor wie der tim die diskussion mit sich selber führt das geht dann ungefähr so yeah nee er hat ja auch rechte tim hat ja recht ist scheiße.
Ich ich habe ich habe nichts sagen also aufruf hier an unsere hörerinnen und hörer da könnt ihr gerne mal auch zu
diskutieren ja wie wie wie ihr das so seht ja also seid ihr irgendwie aus der kirche der man muss überall sichtbar sein und scheiß drauf was dafür regeln und verpflichtungen gelten und man gibt die ganze kontrolle aus der hand
oder äh ja nee äh hier heilige.
Geld dann völlig irgendwelche nur plattform.
Es gibt halt verschiedene plattformen die verschiedene modelle haben so und das ist ja auch nichts neues spotify war dann halt einfach der größte container und führt
angeblich die zahlen halt an das kann sehr wohl sein es gibt auch leute sind der meinung dass irgendwie musik und podcast es geht ja wunderbar zusammen weil das ja am radio ja auch so dass wir jetzt irgendwie der trend und da müsste man halt irgendwie hin.
Und wir in unserer quatsch blase ja haben der sozusagen nichts zu bieten,
läuft ja auch bei der musik ist und so ne
achso ja gut.
Verpasst die zukunft.
Good point und vielleicht hört uns an keiner mehr wir werden alle total irrelevant kann aber auch sagen naja es gibt irgendwie hörer zahlen es gibt relevante höhler hörer zahlen und man muss eben auch schon 'ne qualität des hören uns
auch bewerten und sind leute die uns nicht finden würden weil sie ihre ganze realität nur noch über sport übernimmt eigentlich unsere führerschaft ist
alles fragen auf die ich nicht immer eine gute antwort habe aber die man auf jeden fall mal stellen kann.
Ich habe letztens statistiken angeschaut von netzwerk und falls interessant dass nur drei darf ich gar nicht sagen gibt sofort ärger wahrscheinlich dass nur drei prozent aller
leute die auf netzwerk von facebook kommen und das voll geil alle anderen sind so oh gott die ende den algorithmus werden wir noch gesehen und so was die leute kommen über feed
die kommen auf die startseite die überhaupt nichts die plattform hat nichts zu sagen damit ein bisschen ein bisschen was rüber ist auch gut dafür leute der bock drauf haben aber eigentlich,
unabhängigkeit von so plattform super.
Ja dann kommt aber gleich die social media influencer sagen naja ich nutze euer potenzial nicht und ihr wollt ja dann auch und ihr müsst auch da hin wo die leute sich tummeln und ja ihr bestärkt ja nur in dieser blase,
in gewisser hinsicht im kreis ich kann da alle argumente verstehen aber ich denke man kann da auch 'n gewisses standing entwickeln,
also da würde ich mich wirklich jetzt mal über eure gedanken dazu,
würde mich wirklich mal interessieren also könnt ihr mal.
Kündige das abo wenn ihr dahin geht irgendwas.
Es ist ja.
Ja
Es ist ähnliche ähnliche debatte wem wie mit mit werbefrei et cetera ja es gibt leute die sagen.
Keine werbung.
Uns ist das irgendwie egal andere schreiben in die spenden überweisung rein ja danke dass das dass ich davon verschont bleibe so was halt immer beide seiten,
na gut damit nehmen wir euch jetzt nicht weiter wir müssen uns noch ein paar andere sachen machen.
Wir müssen noch ein video machen.
Genau unsere social media kampagne plan.
Okay ich danke noch kurz dem johannes dem harald und der margret und es fehlt wieder eine person von der ich den zettel zuhause liegen habe aber ich bin jetzt hier in der mitte ebene und es kommt noch es tut mir sehr leid,
so tschüss.
Tschüss bis bald.
Tschüss markus hau ab jetzt.
Ich warte auf die ich will doch tanzen für der abschluss.
Danke abschlussmusik gibt's was nicht doch.
Achso ich hab euch nie zu ende gehört.
Wir könnten zum abschluss machen,
also ich finde diese detox das sieht so ein bisschen aussehen yankee.
Wir schauen mal was passiert.
Okay feierabend jetzt hier ciao.
Tschüss.